Modelling instruction basically kind of turns
things upside down in the way that science
is approached in the high school classroom.
Students are now presented at the beginning
of the unit with basically a lab experience.
Can tables two through five — two through
five — go to one of the tutorials?
One of the four tutorials.
They’re presented with some sort of a system
they can develop questions about themselves
and design experiments to assess these questions.
The data they collect we can then use to create
models that represent not only the system
but then can be generalized to represent any
system that shares these specific characteristics.
The idea is that the students are really constructing
their own understanding through engaging in
this work.
And the work tends to be a little more genuine
and authentic.
As opposed to doing a lab for which theoretically
we should already know the outcome for and
we’re just going to calculate a percent
error for.
So they’re actually engaging in work that
scientists are actually engaging in, constructing
models.